Listening to radio lab radio from W N Y.
S. C. Yep. Hello,
I'm Jet Apple Rod. I'm
Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
and today we have a story from a
longtime contributor of ours, uh,
who's up to something new these
days. A Gregory Warner. Yes.
If you've listened to this program,
you know his work because he's
been on our show so many times.
He brought us stories from upstate
New York about faith healers,
thinks as 12 years ago.
Then a story from Afghanistan
about the quote Afghan Elvis,
a couple of stories from Kenya,
one from Ethiopia and exploring a cure
to alcoholism by some crack in Moscow.
In other words, he's
like all over the place.
He is a foreign correspondent
for national public radio,
and recently NPR decided to
give him his own podcast.
It's called rough
translation and it's killer,
but we're going to just begin today
with sampling one of his new pieces.
It again takes us to a peculiar place
with an improbable result. Yeah.
Here's Greg Warner.
The six months before Mohammad went to
prison with the best six months of his
life,
he'd landed this great job managing a
Pepsi plant and he'd found true love on
his first date. We went to a small
restaurant, where do we leave?
Her name was Ismahan 20 years
old teller at a state bank.
I know we were talking and shyly of
course, you know, she was British I and,
and we realized we want
to get married. That's it.
Love it for censored in a sense. Yeah.
[inaudible]
Mohammad said he was just so struck
by how generous she was smart and they
connected about everything from the
future of their country to the music they
liked. Whatever images the
word Somalia calls to mind.
The Somalia where Muhammad lived
was in a cultural renaissance.
This was 1981 it was under
communist rule and the dictator,
he was a dictator, but he was also a
big fan of Somali culture in music.
Music was sexually a big part of
how Mohammad courted his Mohan.
He made her mix tapes. This was the
80s to song sense, stuff like that.
Yeah. Did you sing or did she
say, oh, she's a bit to sing?
[inaudible]
a few months after Mohammad
and his mom got married,
Mohammed got a phone call from the
director of the local public hospital.
Please help me bring some
donations from the communities.
He was desperate for donations
or medicine for bedding. In fact,
that music loving dictator,
his name was, see at Bari,
he'd cut off supplies to the hospital
in retaliation for an independence
movement in the region. The doctor had
been calling all his friends and secret.
Yeah. We were talking a little time
saying, you know, you work for Pepsi,
you have connections,
you know, people can,
we raise the money discreetly ourselves.
But Mohammad wanted to go big.
I suppose maybe I wanted
to share my happiness.
What do you mean by share your
happiness? You know, contribute.
Cause there are other people
who are less fortunate than us.
Mohammed was in that stage of new love
when you just kinda think the world is
full of good feeling. And if
everybody knew what was going on,
they would do the right thing. And he
takes this bold and pretty risky move.
He writes a letter,
some kind of a nice letter about
the hospital conditions. Yes.
Filling the conditions of the country,
essentially implying that the dictator
is not doing right by us and we've got to
step up ourselves. A
couple of weeks later,
Mohammed and spawn heard a knock on
their door in the middle of the night,
national security to be one. They don't
have no warrant or anything like that.
It's just said we needed to take
him and I could see that my wife
actually member had it and had eyes
what was in her eyes? No love
the tariff.
Mohammad is accused of
treason and sentenced the
life in solitary confinement,
blindfold handcuff and sent to a seven
and this is where the story really
begins. Mohammed cell is tiny,
maybe six feet by six feet concrete walls
hole on the floor for a toilet and a
window
high up that lets in just
a little bit of light.
It's very dark and cook
roots come from the toilet,
cockroaches, cook carrots and
they will fly off the wall,
which you and split them
into their feet. Sweet.
The on their feet would be excreted
from the toilet. Yeah. Yes, yes.
After the cockroaches come the rats
at the mice and the mosquitoes,
the most of the mosquitoes.
Oh, like an engine jet engine.
But even worse than that sound now
is the buzzing in his own mind.
Uh,
because in this prison there is one rule
to a strictly forbidden to talk to your
neighbor. He's forbidden to
speak to the other inmates.
So you will faraway them
backward pacing back and forth.
And this isn't just a tiny place
to walk back and forth tee shots.
So like three short steps forward,
three shorts, those back with resources.
Photos.
Yes.
So that is his life now.
[inaudible]
until one day
he hears a knock on the wall
[inaudible]
and that knock becomes words from
another time and another place.
All happy families are alike.
Unhappy family is unhappy in its own way.
This is rough translation. The show from
NPR bringing you Greg, are you there?
Yeah. Hey guys. Hey, we say,
do you want to just tell us what rough
translation is? Yes. So I've been, uh,
been making a podcast this year. Um,
basically the idea is that in every
episode we follow a conversation we're
having in the United States here, how
that's playing out in a different place.
One episode we might hear about how
fake news is playing out in Ukraine,
which has been getting fake news for
longer and in higher doses than anything
Americans going to imagine.
We're hearing about a trend that's
happening more and more now,
where Chinese women are hiring American
surrogates to have their babies.
So basically every episode we're
trying to do the same thing.
It's just sort of see something we
have, see what the other folks, yeah.
Which is not like what we said.
Yeah. And I guess in this one,
we have a guy locked away in a Somali
prison. Should we just keep playing?
See what happens? Yeah.
Yeah. It's rough translation.
It's eight months into Mohammed's
prison sentence and he's in his cell as
always. He's alone.
Not quite though. There were so
many different types of answers.
Swells is unseen. Tiny one is
really just like watching a film.
Gatesville the way deal.
They look around for food.
Do we have t three t should
have it when you give them time.
It's another world
I would have loved to go
see at that hill. They're,
they're homeless. They
where they were staying,
but I couldn't because it was so concrete.
And then one evening when the guard is
at the other end of the line of cells,
just out of your shot, the guy in
the cell next to Muhammad whispers.
So with the door saying lan
a, B, c through the wall,
then ABC through the wall,
learn a, B, c through the
wall. But he remembers and,
and does that make any sense to
Muhammad at that one 0 million cents?
I look at the world between. So, but
then, but then he knocked on the wall
[inaudible]
and when Mohammed leaned over to the wall,
he could hear this sound that's shot
that too.
So you have a sharp sound
and a kind of dull sound.
And with those two sounds, he immediately
clicks. Oh, this is the alphabet.
Oh, this is the guy saying,
learn this code, this code.
Yeah.
Yes, I understand that.
And he starts with this,
B, c, d, e,
f,
first and alphabet. And then
words. What do you,
what was the first
sentence that you heard?
So number, which means peace in Somalia
and what it means. How are you also,
yeah, no,
but I could've beat that with or that
day fell without doing anything else.
And so Mohammad
can now spend most of the day tapping
back and forth to talk with the guy in the
next cell about politics,
to share a childhood memory.
But at night when he can't sleep,
he turns again to the concrete.
And then again, and again,
I was only sleeping few, maybe half
an hour, then wake up a half an hour.
Mohammed would wake up from a nightmare,
sweaty and in a panic, I guess.
My sleep, are you awake? I can't sleep.
I need to talk.
[inaudible]
when I try to sleep,
when I'm falling asleep,
sitting in my heart face is so fast.
So I was thinking there was space
that this is the smell of death.
What is the smell of death? I think fear.
Mohammed had a lot of fearful
thoughts in that prison cell,
especially about his wife.
I could not imagine how how she is
because there are no news from from the
world,
from those side where it's
really difficult to imagine
where she is even with
she's alive.
Then there was a meaner thought as well.
The government was encouraging
wives to be forced their husbands.
The government was saying, you should
divorce. Yes, of course, Daddy.
Three trustees write in prison.
Even some chefs from granite
faces to support that
divorce in Somali society in Islam is
usually the husband's exclusive. Right,
but there are these Quranic verses that
can allow a wife to choose to divorce
her husband if the husband's
absent for some time and shakes.
Loyal to the dictator,
use those verses to pressure the
wives of political prisoners.
Quite a number of people who
were forced from their request.
All right. I was thinking sometimes the
shoe could, she was only 20 years old.
They'd only been married for three
months and he was sentenced to life.
You think she's probably enjoying herself?
She's living her life
and I am in this place.
At first it's just a little twinge of
resentment and then the feeling comes back
stronger and sharper. He thinks
she should be visiting me,
but wait, she can't visit me.
Nobody come to see this place and
nobody can get in touch and he's still,
you blame her for not getting in touch
with you and what do you think about her
in those moments when you're
blaming her for not visiting you?
Pretty far from love.
You probably hate that
at that particular time.
Every time that Mohammed tapped one
of these dark thoughts onto the wall,
someone was listening and the someone
on the other side of the wall was a
doctor,
doctor at an Abacor is also an inmate in
this prison and is the doctors to these
taps on
the wall. He's also
diagnosing them acute anxiety.
Who was telling me the
symptoms through the wall?
I should tell you that doctor Addon and
Mohammad were actually friends before
prison. Yeah. Yeah. The doctor was
the director of the public hospital.
The one had called him up
and asked him for donations.
He did not ask Mohammed to write that
letter complaining about the hospital
conditions
cause there were no press allowed,
no newspapers, no free press.
And that's the moment the
government decided that they
should do something about
us.
But if the doctor blames Mohammad for
writing the letter that got them both
thrown in prison, he didn't show it.
Every time that Mohammed knocked,
whatever the hour the
doctor would knock back,
he used to have these
nightmares. So he jumps,
he has a knife man and then he
knocks on the, on the wall again.
So I have to wake up and then
again start conversation, you know,
so that they can fall asleep.
I get just like a baby,
you're taking a baby to Tibet and
making you fall asleep, you know?
Okay.
If Dr add and seems fairly unsentimental
about some of the more dramatic aspects
of Mohammed's life, just
like a baby, you know,
it's partly that these two men
are such different personalities.
While Mohammad described that nighttime
arrest as a moment of shock and terror.
Dr Adnan seems to have met those same
secret police with a bag packed and ready
for prison and bag of clothes
and lots and lots of books.
Huh? Why books? Books is the
best friend and in a prison.
Then when you go to the prison that
was taken away, the bag was taken away.
Even old glasses were taken away.
So
tell me about the day you learn the
language. Learn the knocking language.
Well,
okay.
It was the most exciting day in our life.
Okay.
This was the most exciting and
we couldn't sleep. Wait, so Greg,
let me ask this. This knocking,
this is something that they are,
they all were doing together. Yeah.
Particular Line of Eight prisoners.
So these eight prisoners,
there was a particular guy in the,
in the middle there who had once heard
of Morse code and just lying there in
prison one day thought, hey, what if I
indent the language and we can talk? Oh,
so this was actually a homespun?
Yeah, he did not know Morse code.
He just knew of it. And the guards
couldn't hear that. That was some,
that was their own right. I
mean literally they could,
this was kind of the magic of it. They
could be just tapping on the wall.
They could be having a whole conversation
and the guard would have no idea what
they were saying.
We started practicing in the whole day
and the whole night and if there is a
joke and somebody loves everybody starts
knocking on the wall and asking that
thread was that joke about that
that guy starts sending the message,
the joke and it goes from,
I could take an hour to send a tiny joke
from one cell to the next cell to the
next, there were eight of them in
this prison. The gods, of course, they
don't know that we are knocking on
the wall because they can't hear.
And then when they see us all laughing,
they just say, well, this get it.
These guys are also losing their sanity.
Meanwhile, on the other side of the wall,
Mohammed really was worried
that his mind was slipping.
I was frightened enough going to a safe
and area in my mind when I would commit
suicide without knowing,
without wanting to,
is it almost like a, the fear of going
crazy? It was making me crazy. Yes.
The fear, the fear was,
you know you could,
you can imagine people who were crazy
and you could imagine that maybe going
crazy was the point of no return.
So you are frightened of that
while the doctor on his side of the
wall and I was trying to counsel him and
explain to him through the wall and he's
not going to go with Matt and that he's
not going to die, but you can't
cancel person through a wall.
Months go by. Then a whole year,
finally it's two years into their
prison sentence and something happens.
Dr Addin is summoned to the office of
the warden to get a change of clothes.
The room was empty and there was a bench
and they ask you to sit on the bench
and then he asked, he asked one of
the guys to go and bring your back.
Just the whole bag with all your
clothes, your books, everything. Yeah.
And then he you, oh,
you open that bag and then he tells you
to choose something in here to wear and
you don't choose anything else. He
says don't choose anything else. No.
That was the regulation.
The doctor is getting his first change
of clothes since he arrived in prison.
So then you showed back two years later
to choose your next tee shirt. Yes,
but then the doctor turns to the
warden. He looks him right in the eye.
Can I have one book? I said
even I did not expect that he will
agree to give me, so I'll just,
I'll just try it, you
know? And they said, yes,
you can choose one all of your books.
So then I started thinking of the,
Oh, the biggest book I can
take a few minutes later.
If the doctor is walking back to his cell
with the fattest book in his bag under
his arm,
you can picture him fantasizing about
just getting to lie down and read about
when he returns to his cell.
There's that sound at the wall. It's
all clear to me the thought that,
why don't I read this before he went
to the wall and distract the negative
thoughts.
Meanwhile, I'm Muhammad on his side of
the wall. Here's the new set of taps,
have a book club, a book, and
I'm ready to chapter by chapter
and I couldn't credit now, Huh?
Anna Karenina, the famous
novel by Leo Tolstoy,
published in 1878 the English translation
that they're using is 800 pages,
350,000 words, nearly 2
million letters, each letter,
a set of taps so the
doctor prepares himself.
So to start, I took piece of my
pitch sheet and I posted
around around my wrist,
like he's prepping for
a medical procedure,
wrapping the sheet around his
wrist and knuckle because it will,
it will damage my reserve. I
continued like that. So then I started
okay and he started listening.
All happy families are alike.
Each unhappy family is
unhappy in its own way.
Everything was in confusion
and the upland skis house,
the wife had discovered that the
husband was carrying the effect.
The dose taps and that book had on
Mohammed's mind is after the brain.
[inaudible]
is this Michael Barrels
from Portland, Oregon.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology and the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
[inaudible].
Hi y'all.
I'm Jessica Williams and I'm Phoebe
Robinson and we're back this fall with an
all new season of our hit podcast
tutto queens from wny c studios.
Season four is going to be
better than ever. I swear.
We got special guests like Abby
Jacobson, Teagan and Sierra w Kamau Bell,
Queen Latifa,
and more plus stand up from the best
in the Biz and bebe and I live out our
wildest dreams this season. For example,
I met J K Rao wing and I met
Bono. Those aren't the same.
To hear these stories and more,
come on over to two dope queens
wherever you get your podcasts. Oh,
the memories, the memories
bottle. I love you. Not the same.
Okay, we're back.
This is Radiolab and we now return to
the tale told by Gregory Warner from his
new podcast. Rough translation.
The day that the novel Anna
Karenina entered their lives,
marked a new phase for Mohammed
and the doctor. Each morning,
Dr Addin would carefully wrap his hand
and open the novel Mohammed on his side
of the wall,
but listen, when he was stressed,
step on our Katovich sprinkled
some center on himself.
[inaudible] district brought the whole
story to your right pocket book matches
and watch with its double chain and
seals and shaking out his handkerchief
feeling can self-clean fragrant,
healthy and physically at ease.
In spite of his unhappiness,
he walked with a slight swing on each
leg into the dining room where coffee was
already.
If it's been a while since you've
cracked open on a [inaudible],
here's what you need to know. Ana is
a noble woman in 19th century Russia.
She's married to a man
much older than herself.
She goes to a ball and a black velvet
dress line with lace and falls in love
with the soldier count front
skis. He's kind of a rich boy.
Careless and love Mohammed immediately
hates him is because he's also in uniform
and I was hating anything. A uniform.
Actually, this is very impersonal.
Yeah. Mean I can feel
that he's in the military.
And you were in the military prison.
Yeah, I was a military person. Definitely.
See you really didn't like
rod scheme. So anyway,
the soldier of Wronski
heat seals on his heart.
He gets her pregnant even though
she's still married to the other guy.
And then Ana makes a choice that really
changes everything because instead of
having a secret affair, like all
the others in your social set,
she makes her love public. She
leaves her husband and society.
The Russian nobility cut her off.
They isolate her. Wronski is a man,
so he pretty much able to go on
with his life as before, but honest,
realizing how alone she is.
She staying in a room wondering what
Brodsky's up to when he's not with her.
Okay.
Just the same as Mohammed was wondering
what his wife was doing outside the
prison walls. Muhammad reads me
this one sentence from the book,
if you love it hard. So if,
if we love it hot,
he would understand all the difficulty
of that situation and he would treat
squad from it. If he loved her, he
would rescue her from her situation.
It's interesting because on a is traps
by reviews about women and maybe desire
and and all that, but you
are trapped by real waltz.
He says it didn't matter how different
their lives seemed on the outside.
Inside she was suffering all the
time. He felt exactly like Ghana.
He also was jealous, crazily jealous, and
also hating himself for being jealous.
And all of a sudden he meets this
fictional character who is suffering in
exactly the same way.
And this suffering is driving her into
a state that Mohammad most feared for
himself going to assist an area in my
mind when I would commit suicide without
knowing, without wanting to.
So it's now 750 pages into the book
and two months surpass since the doctor
first started tapping the
book letter by letter.
Ana and Bronski are now living
in Moscow and it's summer,
so it's hot and suffocating.
And on this particular day,
Vronsky is off visiting his mom,
which on a hates because she thinks
she's trying to set him up with a young
princess and Ana's in the state of
mind where she both thinks that she's a
burden to front ski and she thinks
he'd be better off without her,
but also she wants him to suffer her
absence. The way she's suffering.
It's in this state that ANA finds
herself walking down a train platform.
The train is hurdling down the tracks
and this thought possessor.
Fie knew what she had to do,
whether rapid lights step.
She went down the steps that led from
the tank to the rails and stopped quite
near the approaching train.
As Mohammad is listening to this and
he's thinking about, she is about to do
[inaudible] for her, but he realizes
his tears are not just for Ana.
That's when I remember my wife.
He's remembering Ismahan his
wife missy. She's suffering.
Yes. The books,
the one that brought me back to
think about how to Latin end,
he finds himself asking a question that
in two years in prison he has not asked
himself before. Did I do well in
those few months we were together?
Had he been a good husband?
Yeah. Should I treat a CBC
instead of thinking she's left him and
also hating himself for thinking that
she's left him.
He's thinking why did he take himself
away from her by writing that stupid
newsletter? Maybe we could have
done it in a different way.
That letter that got them all
thrown in prison. You'd be,
you could have talked to them and putting
himself in his wife's shoes like that.
It kind of took him out of his own misery.
He could think about like
she suffered the worst,
you know than me cause I was only in
prison but she was in the outside where he
goes from self-pity to pity for her.
Oh I think that's related
to the book tell story.
It's fate actually famous for that.
That's like his magic crazy talent.
Can you say more about
that magic? Crazy talent.
Cause like when I was rereading, I
told Elif Batuman about Muhammad Story.
You've heard her reading the Tolstoy
passages for us. She's also a writer,
novelist herself and totally obsessed
with unaccredited. I like it a lot.
When I told her about
Mohammad's experience,
she had this idea about why that book
in particular might've helped Muhammad
make this mental leap from hating his
wife to imagining everything through her
eyes tell story gives a lot of weight to,
to all of the characters like even
suggest like a newlywed young girl.
You spend a lot of time
and her thoughts and the,
there's like a scene where she's trying
to eat a mushroom on a plate and it
keeps flipping from under her fork
ton. I ain't even been to spirit,
this obedient, slippery mushroom.
We had a shaking delays
through which had showed why.
It's a book that takes the subjectivity
of young women seriously and not just
young women. Everyone that
servants and I'm the dog.
There's a hunting scene in this that's
actually goes to the perspective of the
dog and everything just seems so
true. You read that and you're like,
that's definitely what that dog was
thinking and so she says the experience of
reading Tolstoy is the experience of
being constantly confronted with how
differently. The same thing can look
from a slightly different perspective.
Like he's just, he never gets bored
of showing that and in the book,
the characters themselves actually judge
each other and then are able to expand
that and to see each other a
little bit more generously.
That's what LF thinks that Tolstoy's
book gave to Muhammad is different.
It's Kent did that. It definitely,
definitely in a place like,
like that prison people
become very selfish.
You think everybody has forgotten about
me at the beginning for concern about
me, so
I nobody cares about me like that.
But when you think about other people's
situation, then you, you understand.
It helped me survive. It's
helping me even sleep better.
Tolstoy actually had one more
role to play in Mohammed's life.
Eight years after his arrest,
the Somali political winds had shifted
and the dictator was trying to appease
his enemies. Mohammad and the
others were suddenly released.
He discovered his region of
Somalia was flattened by civil war,
but Muhammad also discovered
something else. His wife is mine.
She was still his wife.
She had not given up on him and she had
suffered in his absence working at the
state bank.
She'd been pressured by your boss to
divorce the trader Mohammed when she
refused. She was relocated and by
the time Mohammed was released,
she was living in a
refugee camp in Germany.
She couldn't even make it
back to Somalia to see him.
So I wait to another, uh,
that was for another say about 10
months, I think, to, to see each other.
Finally,
they figured out a way
that they can reunite in a
neighboring country and though
it's been almost a decade
since they've seen each other,
you recognized her immediately from a
distance and it's, they drew closer.
Ismahan opens her arms to give her
husband a hug and he reaches out.
And all that he could do in
that moment is shake her hand.
Yeah.
Why do I not feel as I
felt even even in prison,
I was feeling so much in love
with that. And yet when we met,
it wasn't the same. She was like a
stranger or something like that.
Wow. I mean, I was asking myself,
why are you not as in
love with heart as before
[inaudible]
and is, this was a moment that we
found really interesting and uh,
you know, as we were talking about it
with Greg, oh no, no, no. It was a studio.
Greg said that it was really in
this moment, this period of doubt,
he was overcome by a momentary doubt of
the possibility of setting up that new
life you dreamed of on the way that
the book came back to Muhammad again.
Except this time he didn't think of
the main character Anna Karenina.
He thought of a different character in
the book. A guy by the name of Levon.
This is a character who
is, uh, also in love,
also has like strong emotions.
And like Muhammad in that one moment
with his wife love and spends the entire
book just racked by doubts,
doubts about everything,
an eternal dissatisfaction with yourself,
vain attempts to improve and failures
and then internal expectation of the
happiness and standing
there with his wife,
not just weirded out by his own lack of
feeling. Mohammad had two thoughts like,
oh,
I'm like living in this moment and
what happens to live in at the end?
And what's really cool about Levin's
conclusion at the end of the book is he
finally just decides like,
I'm not going to worry about
how weird my feelings are.
Like he doesn't actually come,
he doesn't make himself whole as he
wants to be. He wants to the whole book.
He wants to be, um, fully in love with
Kitty and not just with his heart,
but with his mind and his soul.
And he wants to be a good Christian and
everything has to sort of make sense to
him, but you know,
but he's just a complicated sort of guy
and he's got many different feelings.
But at the end of the book he
kind of feels like, you know,
I'm going to stop just thinking obsessive
Lee about how awkward I am in this
situation and I'm just going to do and
I'm supposed to, I'm going to be the dad,
I'm gonna be the husband
and Mohammed thought to himself, uh,
like maybe I need to do that too because
like who knows where I'm at right now.
I was in a cell for eight years in the
prison in a way you hadn't to living,
you are still inside
yourself. You had not,
you have to open any figured like opening
back up is probably going to take some
time
and some work we have to learn to love
each other again and that he says is what
they did.
Hey told us. That had a lot to do with it.
You think Tolstoy helps you fall
in love again? Yeah, I mean,
I mean feeling of, look, you know,
it wasn't so easy to become a love again.
This man has been experienced as
she was leaving [inaudible] life.
It's difficult for people to grow the,
to live with someone who has been
in solitary confinement for so long.
I was probably very difficult to
live with at that particular time.
And you're saying that knowing that you
are hard to live with, knowing yes. Yes.
It's made it easier for us to
talk to each other, to live,
to learn to live with each other. Because
you knew that yes, your heart was not.
Yes, yes. Quite working yet. Yeah.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] I shouldn't be
the monument for that book.
Hey, one last thing. There is
someone else to give credit to here.
Besides the great Russian author,
every detail the Tolstoy
wrote into that book,
every perspective shift that helped
Mohammad escape his prison cell.
All of a sudden it has had to be tapped
out on a concrete wall by a friend.
No,
I could imagine him getting tired
because he was at work and God at ain't
working out.
Dr Addons said that Mohammed was his
last patient after their release.
He was just too out of practice to
return to medicine and after prison,
the doctor did try to read the novel
on a Corena. Again, I went a bull show,
but when I tried to read the, couldn't
read it too many bad memories,
but he knew someone who
could use it. Somebody,
a friend who was in prison here in
Samala, the journalist, a friend,
and I took that book to him and
I told him that's the best thing,
Mr President you can have
in a prison is a book.
[inaudible]
Great Warner. Thank you guys.
You wanna check out more
episodes of rough translation.
We'll link you to it@radiolab.org or
you can go to npr.org/rough translation
[inaudible].
This episode of rough translation was
edited by Marianne McCune and was produced
by Jess Jang. Thank you too.
Elizabeth Send Ges Backman,
who introduced Greg to Dr Rodin.
She interviewed Dr Rodin at the Hargeisa
international book fair in Somaliland.
The rough translation team had editorial
help from Jacob Goldstein, Noah King,
Nick Fountain, Robert Smith,
Brian [inaudible], Lupo Koski,
and Santa Claus Krakow.
Elif Bachman is the author
of the possessed adventures
with Russian books and
the people who read them.
Her new novel is the idiot,
the music by John Ellis, warm
music from blue dot sessions.
And our Dylan Keefe threw in some
music as well. Uh, all right,
well we should go. I'm
Jad. I have them run.
I am Robert Povich and thank
you very much for listening.